The Beatles Worst Experience
The Beatles arrived in Manila to give two
concerts in early July of 1966.
This was to be one of their gigs on their
1966 final-ever tour; they had just finished
a few very pleasant gigs in Germany.
There were “bad vibes” almost from the
word “go” as the boys arrived at the Manila
airport.
Ringo: “I hated the Philippines.
It was like that hot/ gun/ Spanish inquisition
attitude.”
George stated, “As soon as we got there,
it was bad news.
There were tough gorilla-little men in short
sleeves who acted very melancholy.”
The boys were greeted at the airport by severe-looking
armed guards and were sternly instructed to
get on a boat.
A bit scared already, they complied.
This was actually the first time in their
time together that they were separated from
their manager or any of their aides while
on tour.
They were taken to a limo and solemnly escorted
to their hotel.
No one except them knew it, but they had another
reason to be scared.
The Manila guards had confiscated the boy’s
traveling bags- which contained marijuana,
which was illegal there as in many places.
(Fortunately for the Fab Four, their bags
were not searched and their secret stash was
never discovered.)
At the time in Manila, the country was ruled
by the dictatorship regime of Ferdinand Marcos
and as soon as the Beatles got settled in,
they were told they were to attend a reception
for the country’s matriarch.
Tired and jet-legged, they politely informed
the guards they would not be attending.
A bit of arguing back and forth went on, but
the boys stuck to their guns and settled in
for the day.
They were soon joined in their room by their
roadies, a few aides and their manager, Brian
Epstein.
They played two concerts that night and all
went well.
(They performed before two huge crowds of
30,000 and 50,000).
Their dressing room had been “a mess”
and they had been served a horrible meal of
corn flakes with lumpy, sour milk and some
other horrible-looking food, but thought nothing
of it.
Little did they realize what was in store
for them.
The next morning, as they arose, Ringo and
John tried to order breakfast from room service.
There was an ominous quiet on the other end
of the phone line and their order was not
taken.
As the boys casually turned on the TV, they
saw films of President Marcos and a huge group
of disappointed children with tears rolling
down their faces.
Apparently, the Beatles had disappointed and
insulted the Madame President and crushed
the hearts of the little kids by “snubbing”
them.
(Presumptuously, Madame Marcos had told the
young hopeful children that the Beatles would
be making an appearance and that they could
meet them in person without first clearing
it with the Beatles or their management.)
Moments later, a newspaper arrived with the
headline “Beatles Snub President”.
After much ruckus, increasingly worried manager
Epstein decided to issue a formal apology
over Manila television.
As Brian’s apology was being broadcast on
TV, the picture mysteriously went off and
dead air was transmitted to the viewing public.
Now very afraid, the whole crew packed as
quickly as they could and asked to be driven
to the Manila airport.
Instead of the huge motorcade that had welcomed
them the previous day, there was just a car
and a cheap one-motorcycle escort.
As they arrived at the Manila airport, the
band and their entourage were summarily dropped
off.
Forced to carry their own bags, the small
group hastily made tracks for the gates, but
were soon greeted by a huge, hostile, bloodthirsty
mob of furious Filipinos.
As the frazzled group made a mad dash for
the gates, the Beatles and their aides were
kicked, punched, spit on and yelled at with
angry epithets.
“We treat you like ordinary passenger!
Ordinary passenger!”, the airport personnel
unsympathetically informed them.
(Strangely, the Beatles aides were all attacked
more furiously than the Beatles themselves-
the boys were to remember their hapless chauffeur,
Alf, getting kicked, bloodied, and pushed
down a flight of stairs.)
John and Ringo ran for sanctuary behind a
small group of Catholic nuns, while George
ran for refuge behind a nearby Buddhist monk.
(Thank goodness for the ever present airport
clergy.)
Ringo got decked by an uppercut and was kicked
on the ground.
He also suffered a sprained ankle from the
melee.
By a strange “coincidence”, the escalator
was “out of order”, so the beaten-up young
men ran as quickly as they could, up the steps
to relative safety.
Bruised and bloodied, they all finally made
it on board the plane.
The terrified group waited nervously in the
severe humidity- afraid for their lives.
An announcement came over the intercom, requesting
a meeting with manager Epstein, their press
agent and the Beatles’ personal assistants,
Mal and Neil.
As Mal solemnly walked out of the plane, he
asked the Beatles to “tell Lil I love her.”
(Lil being his wife.)
It seems the “airport-leaving Manila tax”
was being levied and it just happened to be
the same amount the Beatles had been paid
in currency.
Epstein paid the extortion money and the men
were permitted to return to the plane.
(The amount was reportedly around $18,000-
$125,000 today.)
After another long wait, the exhausted, terrified
group got permission to take off and fly home.
Ringo, always the most easy-going member of
the group, was to remember the Manila trip
of 1966 as “the worst experience of my life…
I thought they were going to put us in jail”,
he recalled.
Peace-loving George was later interviewed
on television and said he’d like to “drop
a bomb” on the Philippines.
The Beatles made a vow never to return to
Manila or the Philippines and the vow was
firmly kept.
(Oh yes- one final, bizarre tidbit: the 80,000
fans in Manila the Beatles performed before
on that July day in 1966 is still the record
for the largest number of people the Beatles
ever performed before on a single day!)